questo è quello che si merita benvenuti
solida oggi nuovissimo gioco mai giocare
con il ladro spaventoso questo gioco di
chi e mazzieri bel robert sarebbe ladro
spaventoso dovrebbe essere un parente lo
stesso di spiriti share come i fratelli
cattivi i the seas bling vi ricordate
vi è piaciuto tantissimo con il
videogioco questo non so se sia il
nipote di scherzi sono il marito di
scary teacher
scrivetemi voi nei commenti se sapete
che parente professione ladro e mi
raccomando mettetevi comode di prendi
tipo cose lasciate un bel mi piace entro
sei sette casi ai 14 30 è però gli altri
stanno per entrare in casa ma per vedere
un film che non si dimenticheranno mai
eccoli dicono che come rubiamo in questa
casa e l'altro ladro ha detto beh
abbiamo una casa tutta per noi siamo un
ricordiamo c'è un film volevo stare
attenti dalle camere di sicurezza che
non andiamo nelle stesse stanze dove
sono i ladri cosa devo fare questa prima
missione devo trovare un v un film ora
ruda mezzo da mettere nella tv così si
spaventano film horror dove lo devo
cercare aiuto o forse qualche anno di
sotto
oramai temendo e con il mare la nome di
norma come dei prestiti
piano piano casa oddio cosa mi hanno
chiuso dello stato che io ero a prova
vitale dai ora sappiamo dov'è il film
horror
ed è nella cucina mi sembra che fosse la
cucina c'era una batteria in realtà
allora se non sbaglierò alcuno di sonno
sinistra non si distrae e apre la porta
e spara si pratica bisogna scambiare il
film horror con l'altro dvd che un dvd
commedia così loro penseranno di quella
rubino divertendo bravo lei fattura
scappa non ci abbandona accorgermene
ok fatto che a riguardo l'estero si
chiama uno dei due pensa di essere in
salvo adesso vediamo la loro reazione
andando adesso ecco stanno dicendo
questo mi sarà divertentissimo così
imparate ladri stanno provando a rubare
la macchina di tuo padre ci pensiamo noi
a fargli un bello scherzo scherza tutto
ok hanno detto che allora devi trovare
qualcosa per bucare cosa campo dell'oro
io della macchina loro tavolini caso
della finestra come fatto vederli ma
dovete mai andare allora nel garage
garage se trova fra il giro forse dietro
lui controlla le telecamere ok
no devi occupare guai a carasco in
funzione tesoro cioè quello sulle cose
l'ho presa ma non penso che mi servirà
va bene la macchina e questi forzieri
forcieri dei pirati manette dove passa
io di un livello fa di un piano che
controlla che i ladri non si stiano
avvicinando no come si stanno
avvicinando e qui dietro aiuto bravo che
quello che possiamo trovare qualcosa per
per bucare le cose dell'olio aiuto per
anno arrivando il the styles
eccolo questo rosso questo rosso questo
questo questo di qua di qua dove ok ora
vigore delle norme stamani capisca ma la
stiamo scappa scappa scappa
e per tornare scatta scatta quasi 7 si è
mancato di più c'è mancato davvero poco
ragazzi ce la siamo fatta adesso andiamo
a vedere che cosa succede con la
macchina non vedo l'ora di vedere la
materia ecco adesso si possono
confondere la macchina 20 grideranno di
gioia quando troveranno il ladro gli ha
detto guarda a questi giocattoli magari
valgono molto e l'altro di addetta ma
devi trovare qualcosa che vale di più
quindi stiamo cercando di gioielli il
gioco ha già dato un suggerimento e ci
ha detto di trovare il formaggio il
formaggio sicuramente in cucina bruciano
sempre il tubo che giusto questo ciò che
veramente molto più difficile di scary
tre reti blink kenya ma in cucina a
questo ufficio ma è diversa allora la
casa ma c'è un martello
la cucina è una chiave blu non ci serve
avesse effettivamente molto che sarà la
cucina anche questo ho solo provato
twitter o meno da pranzo si si
ora deve essere qua vicino al forte con
il famoso pretino ok dobbiamo ora
lasciare il formaggio per terra così
arriva il topo lo possiamo prendere
dov'è allora uno in palestra e uno dove
fanno forse dopo lo trovi fuori
effettivamente dai te un panino vieni
qua abbiamo il formaggio in mano al tema
premurano la trappola per topi forse era
questo che ci mancava esattore ci
mancasse un coraggio e nasconditi
formaggio aperto la finestra bravo ok ok
ho messo il formaggio nella gabbietta
ora dovrebbe andare un topo dai entrate
e cross
ok prendiamolo ora dobbiamo cercare la
scatola di gioielli sì ecco la scatola
di gioielli ok ho messo il topo dentro
ok ora devo mettere il formaggio dentro
scappare scappiamo che bravo scappiamo
scappiamo scappiamo
[Musica]
ok scappiamo capiamo scappiamo nolo
forte è chiusa
eccoli hanno preso una scatola bisognerà
ce l'ho fatto mi è sorta di finestra
i ladri stanno per assaggiare qualcosa
di molto dell'invidioso vediamo che
scherzetto li prepareremo stanno
mangiando ha detto ai vorrei assaggiare
quel pezzo di pollo dice no perché tutti
si è mangiato nel mio bis primi e
biscotti hanno detto che vogliono i
biscotti mi hanno già trovato
non ho già all'entrata devo trovare
qualcosa da mischiare con i biscotti
ok abbiamo ripreso il livello
dall'inizio e ora stiamo nell'altro
bagno ed ecco come il dentifricio i
biscotti mettiamo il dentifricio
ora basta scendere vicine come 1
dicembre la prima fame si creano un
attimo perché ho paura tregua difficile
tra tutti e due lì non mi tiene il
campionato sopra che i loro sono giudizi
si no ecco la faccia a faccia con joe
mettere qui ok hai messi bis colline
tutela dentifricio brutte ti devo aprire
prima però ecco li fa prendiamo il di
dentifricio no allora il dentifricio
eccolo preso ma vi mette del di prigioni
biscotti a deve richiuderli richiede ora
ora devi mettere il sale di nel latte
scappando aiuto
nola protettivo scappiamo dal garage si
è trovato kappadoss capivo dal garage
ok bravo p
menù della baby queste ma che ce
l'abbiamo fatto ma lo mettiamo una
reazione che dovrai biscotti poi pure il
latte i ladri saranno scioccati da
quello che troveranno nella forte
richiamo che combinano il libro del
ladro ha detto che dal libro ha letto
che tutti i ladri sono diventati ricchi
rubando dalle cassaforti che dice ma non
dobbiamo prima trovarla la cassaforte
come le disse allora devo trovare
qualcosa per tagliare il cavo quale
provo forse il capo della cassaforte
allora qui c'è una cosa che l'art mese
forse questo che quindi ok forse questo
può servire per tagliare il capo ma dove
starà la casa fare questo probabilmente
più per una serratura
ecco il cavo
il che ci servirà il cavo prendiamo
anche questo ma rimane un prodotto va
bene saremo dentro casa e speriamo di
trovare qualcosa per tagliare a tentare
sta scendendo le scale questo motto ma
questa è la pasta sia si può spostare
però a prenderla così in braccio ma non
glielo puoi tirare il testo c'è qualcosa
che era proprio vitale da letto siamo
forti speriamo l'ho capito quale sarà lo
scherzo questa volta ma sicuramente sarà
divertente nicolosi preso avanti può
andare e con uno scotch creare
praticamente dobbiamo fare o lalla
roncarà buche dalla lampada passa alla
cassaforte
fin quando lui andrà attaccarono la
si tratterà la corrente
no no no dai questa volta geometra se
non sbaglio era questa stanza no non è
questo
eccola qui c'è la cassaforte
allora selezioniamo questo no
bisogna tagliare il filo non sono bravo
elettricista si trova lì ma ti posso
credere.ho spento l'interruttore ok
adesso togliamo il filo ok ha tagliato
il filo poi abbiamo fatto l'estensione
dobbiamo solo mettere il nastro adesivo
ok dobbiamo però nascondere tutto questo
che abbiamo fatto con il mobile
spingi immobile ok ora dobbiamo scappare
dalla per la decima volta dobbiamo
rifare troveremo a spegnere la luce
perché poi tagliamo il cavo hanno messo
pure la ok cavo tagliato ora chiamo mi
fischiano scappiamo più amata ma
dobbiamo scappare
[Musica]
ci siamo nascosti in bagno non so se
funzionerà speriamo stanno salendo
speriamo che non derivi ruba in bagno ma
che vadano della camera con con la
cassaforte per spiegare però rivedetevi
dalla camera ecco lista ma vediamo cosa
succede questo è quello che si meritano
elettrificati libero noi ma capelli
prima che ragazzi questo raschieri
auburn non abbiamo fini tutti i livelli
perché davvero molto difficile questo
video sarebbe durato una o dall però se
volete il continuo in cui proviamo anche
gli altri livelli gli altri scherzi che
saranno anche pjanic in questo video di
30 mila mi piace insisterà anche la
seconda parte ora vi lasciamo 4 pensa e
linee su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite